الهدف الرئيسي للحرب ضد روسيا في الوقت
الراهن هو القتال من اجل التمسك بصوليدار
وبخمود المدينه الواقعتين في شرق البلاد
والتي تسع روسيا للسيطره عليهما باي ثمن
لتغيير مسار الحرب وفقه
القضيه الاولى
بشكل عام
وما هي الخطوات التي يجب ان يتخذها القاده
في الايام المقبله كما نقشنا الوضع مع
تزويد القوات بالسلاح
الذين احتفظ بمواقعهم والحقوا خسائر كبيره
بالعدو على حديقه تاتي هذه التصريحات للرد
على مزاعم روسيا ان قواتها تقترب اكثر من
السيطره
الخميس بالعمل الضخم والاعمال البطوليه
لقوته
لقد تم القيام بعمل بطولي ليس فقط في
سوليدار ولكن في العديد من المناطق التي
يتم فيها تنفيذ العمليات الهجوميه نحن
سنتذكر هؤلاء الابطال الذين فقدوا حياتهم
والذين يهتمون بالجرحى وفق وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه فان الوضع الصابون في سوليدار
حيث تجري المعارك الاشرس والاناف السيطره
على سوليدار هذه المدينه الصغيره التي
دمرت تماما ستكون بمثابه تحقيق انتصار
عسكري بعد العدد من الانتكاسات وخاصه بعد
خساره مدينه خرسون المهمه في ديسمبر
الماضي كما ستكون نقطه انطلاقا للغزو
المناطق اخرى من مقاطع الشرقيه التي لا
تزال تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه لا سيما
مدينه بخمول الاسراتيجيه والقريبه